Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcasts.
I'm sorry about the recording here I am in Washington DC and I forgot to bring
my laptop because I did not pack the night before because I went out with some
friends and we hung out and I was like,
Oh,
you know,
I'm only leaving for a couple of days.
I just wake up the morning,
throw a couple of shirts or pants and a fucking backpack and I'll be fine.
And uh,
you know,
it didn't work out and I forgot my fucking laptop.
So if you're listening to this right now,
it's on a Thursday.
It's a fucking miracle because somehow I figured out how to download the Dropbox
APP and send this thing to my fucking,
uh,
Mike,
my good friend Andrew to put this thing up.
Um,
so we'll see.
And I've already made an attempted this and it was really quiet and then the
screen wants to screen,
cuts out the recording stops.
So occasionally I have to touch the fucking screen to keep this thing going.
So in other words,
it's going to be a really fucked up podcast here.
All right?
So just hang in there with me.
That's all I need you to do is hang in here.
And by the way,
I'm going to give you guys a couple of travel tips.
All right?
A lot of people go out and they buy those stupid bows fucking headsets,
those noise canceling things where somehow it,
it mimics the frequency of whatever the fuck is going on in the,
the area around you.
So then you can't hear anything.
Um,
you know,
so then you ear doesn't vibrate.
I have no fucking idea.
Or is your vibrating like a motherfucker?
You just can't hear it right now.
I have no idea.
But all I know is there a lot of fucking money.
Just go get yourself some plugs.
Tiny stick.
Jamson fucking ear plugs.
I brought some this morning and I was so psyched that I did because I got on the
flight and there was this store,
this God bless her and I know you're not supposed to call them stewardess.
All right?
You're not supposed to call him that.
What?
He's supposed to call him now.
Huh?
What was flight attendance?
Is that we supposed to call them?
That's right.
You know why?
Because stewardess was a,
uh,
it was a,
it was a racial slur back in the day,
you know?
Okay.
Don't,
don't,
those were fighting words and they had to march on Washington and all is what
the fuck was wrong with stewardess?
Yeah.
Flight attendant,
flight attendant,
you know,
like you helping somebody fly.
You're not,
you know,
you're,
you're a,
you're a fucking maitre d slash waitress.
You multitasking.
Alright.
Stewardess,
maitre d and waitress,
euro,
uh,
a matress,
whatever the fuck you was.
So this lady's on the plane,
right?
This lady,
God bless her,
she's sweet as hell,
but she's just super fucking Nice.
Super fucking chatty.
She won't shut the fuck up.
All right.
And she's annoying the shit out of me,
but I got my earplugs.
She was,
you know,
those,
those stewardesses that they just,
they just lack,
like I,
they just,
they just go into mental.
Okay.
You know,
as they go row to row to row.
And then if they're asking basically the same question,
you know,
would you like some snacks?
You know what I mean?
They,
they have an inability to improvise that line.
Like,
would you like some snacks?
Excuse me,
snacks,
anybody.
Hey,
how you doing?
I've got some snacks.
You know,
they got there,
I just banged out five rows,
did not have a problem.
I could have done another 15 before I repeated.
But you know,
the stewardesses or male stewardess,
this whatever the fuck they are,
we have an inability to do that.
This is what I had.
And she had a fucking super annoying voice and she was handing out this survey
thing to everybody and she was just going down the aisle.
She's coming from behind me.
I just kept hearing pride in me.
Pardon me?
And um,
she finally comes up to me and she goes,
pardon me?
And it's like,
well,
are you trying to get by?
Like what do you fucking saying?
Right.
Why didn't you fucking saying pardon me?
Pardon me?
Why do you keep saying,
pardon me the exact same way?
Pardon me?
Um,
and then finally somebody didn't respond to her and she went,
pardon me,
would you like to fill out our survey?
She was doing that.
The whole fucking flight.
What was killing me was I was,
well,
I seem to be the only person getting annoyed by her because everybody else just
kept talking to her,
kept asking her questions,
and then he had to hear her annoying fucking voice and I just want to yell out,
will you stop fucking talking to it?
Just let it go button.
I it.
Yeah.
That's why I said it.
Just let it fucking go by.
Get it Outta here.
Don't engage.
I was literally treatment the way used to treat like when I was living in New
York,
how you treat it.
Crazy person.
The second that came on your subway car,
the fucking rule was don't look at it,
don't look at it and it won't see you and it'll go right by you become fucking
invisible.
But the second you make eye contact,
it's over and his fucking jerk off in front of me.
You know,
goals.
This is what they offer on United.
I haven't flown United in a while.
Bill.
Really like you're a professional passenger.
You dumb.
Fuck nobody cares.
Nobody cares that you know what the fucking snacks are on Piedmont and whatever
the fuck you fly.
Transworld they are.
I'm the retreads world.
There are usually some good and on the apple.
Um,
of course he's right in front of me and I was just staring daggers into the back
of his head.
But anyways,
I can't really complain about her because she was super nice,
but her voice was so fucking annoying and she would just be like,
wow.
Yeah.
Wow,
wow.
Oh,
I know.
Five fucking hours or that the only way to describe it,
do you guys ever see that movie misery?
Imagine if that movie was rated g right?
Like she wasn't fucking like Sonya feed off like she did in the book or just
broke your ankles in the movies.
Right.
She wasn't doing that shit,
but just like James Caan,
you couldn't fucking leave.
You were trapped,
you know,
but it's ready to g it's only for five fucking hours.
It's exactly what it was.
Like,
you know,
I was sweeping and at one point when I opened my eyes,
I thought she was going to be right in my face.
Like that fucking lady there,
whatever her name is.
Elizabeth Cole Harrington.
What was the name of that?
She's a fucking great ass Elizabeth base.
Nancy base.
Why don't think Elizabeth?
Because she looks like Elizabeth.
Um,
same way I look like a skippy.
Let's plow ahead here.
So anyways,
he finally fucking land.
Um,
you know it was great.
Two was the Wifi did not work on the plane.
Why the fuck you would want?
Why fly?
You're already closer to the sun.
You're already getting radiated.
Let's fucking add a satellite.
Just fucking Zap and the top of your fucking skull for the entire five hours.
I'm calling it right now.
Somebody is going to die as some fucking a Wifi shit in the air.
I don't know what's going to happen.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Oh good.
Oh,
it's still going.
I saw the screen cut out and I was like,
oh fuck.
Did I have to start it over again?
Yeah.
What'd you do if there was an ax murder just walked into my room and that was
the level of emotion I had.
Oh,
no,
no.
That was my acting ability.
Um,
AH,
fuck.
I thought at the screen went black.
I was going to shut off again,
like the,
uh,
like I did last time.
Mini heart attack.
They don't,
what the fuck come back on.
Come back on.
Where did you go?
Why does it keep cutting out on me?
I need to see that it's recording or I'm going to be freaking out here.
Um,
and for all you people laugh for me right now.
Fuck you.
I'm an old man.
I don't understand these things.
I don't pretend to understand them.
So anyways,
I um,
so I land Washington,
Dallas,
like a fucking inexperience Douche.
Every time I go to DC I always say,
you know what?
Next time I'm going to land it,
Ronald Reagan,
that's actually,
you know,
fucking in the downtown area rather than 45 fucking miles outside of the city.
But fortunately a,
I landed at seven o'clock and the traffic was headed out rather than him.
But,
uh,
there's a couple helacious fucking airports like that.
Like next time you go to Dallas,
don't,
don't go to their main fucking,
uh,
those airports where they're an airport and they also have their own subway
system.
You really don't want to be,
cause they're usually way the fuck outside.
I mean,
I guess Dallas is
Dallas isn't that bad.
You know what sucks about Dallas is when you go to connect,
you know when you go to connect,
um,
you never in the right terminal.
And the way they did it is it goes a,
B,
c,
d like A's on top,
bees on the bottom.
She's on top ds on the bottom.
And I think there's an AA or something like that.
Except the thing goes in a circle.
Is that Mike Vick on the fucking Steelers?
Well,
the hell did that happen?
Okay.
Do Ben Roethlisberger I saw
him the other day with just like a regular shirt on.
He looks like some fucking fan and the upper deck.
He,
that guy is just,
he's fucking aging.
You got,
you know what it hats off to him for age,
allowing himself to age naturally.
You know what I mean?
Like Tom Brady,
he's like the fucking hot chick walking around in fucking uggs and stuff.
Getting his hair highlighted,
experimenting with different haircuts.
You know,
Ben Roethlisberger is like,
you know,
a character actor or an out of shape actress.
You know,
like if he was an actress,
they call what he's doing right now.
Brave.
You know what I mean though?
He's big on that.
They're big on that word and the acting community,
everything's fucking brave.
And you did the movie without makeup.
It was such a brave performance.
Okay.
Oh fuck.
Are they wearing pink again?
This God damn.
Yeah.
You know what I like about it though?
There's only a little bit of pink and I called it right now the NFL is gradually
trying to phase out the pink October next year.
They're just going to have a wristband because eventually somebody,
okay,
look off fat is fucking spaces.
Ben Roethlisberger space,
dude.
He goes to buffalo wild wings all week and then he just comes out in the slings
it on Sunday.
Man,
you've got to love that guy unless you're a woman in a bathroom.
But other than that,
this guy is just a fucking old school.
He's an old school football player,
right?
That was a low blow.
You got acquainted twice,
you know,
twice as the keyword in that sentence twice.
Um,
I'm calling it right now.
They're gradually gonna phase out this pink shit in the NFL because eventually
somebody with enough poll is going to do a research cause going to do some
research and realize how little fucking money trickles down to anybody,
right?
I you don't want to put the fuck do I know.
I've just gone on a couple of websites anyways.
Um,
what am I doing here?
I'm watching a football game and doing this isn't fucking add maniac.
Let me turn my back here.
You can't turn your back on football.
It's like turning your back on America.
Hey,
you know what?
Somebody came up with a great retort here for a,
you know how those fucking English constant,
all those fucking douchebags and think they're so fucking smart.
They always go,
why are you cal football?
Football might you know you fucking carry with your hands.
And she called fucking handball.
Somebody tweeted me that.
His friend goes,
well then why the fuck don't you call it feet ball?
You're using you using both feet.
All right there.
There's a little clever one right back at you.
If you guys were so fucking smart,
you would've called it feet ball,
not football.
How about that?
Huh?
We'll chip the tat there.
Look at this fucking awful shit they laid out here.
You know what I hate when?
I hate the arena.
When somebody has let an appetizer and their consideration of an appetizer is an
array of different pickles.
You know I got to fucking bread sticks here that looked like chopsticks.
Some fucking cheese that look like,
well,
I guess Jesus like rotted milk.
Anyways,
what do we got here?
Got some nuts.
I don't like this hotel.
The hotel I'm staying at is for young people.
It's for people in their twenties,
right?
For them to fucking do selfies and flashed a peace sign and then Hashtag Yolo,
it's one of those fucking hotels.
I'm an old man.
All right?
I don't like air conditioning.
It gives me a cold and my,
my,
it makes my throat raspy.
How the fuck do you shut it off?
Does that option exist or did apple build this fucking thing and it's no longer
an option?
I'm really down on their fucking products.
Everybody.
Did you have,
you noticed that,
that you,
you're only allowed two options now with all of their shit.
It's basically a do it now or maybe later.
Remind me later.
They've completely gotten rid of the fuck off option.
Fuck off.
I don't want this.
You know,
and I'll tell you right now,
it's a slippery slope.
Um,
I think people are going to graduate.
They get used to not having an option.
Like here,
this is what it is.
This is what it is.
And you can either do it this way or you can do it that way,
but you can not opt out on any fucking level.
And then they're going to gradually microchip us.
Oh,
fucking steal is straight out.
I got to tell you,
Mike Vick is looking,
really sharpen that stealer,
that Steelers jersey.
You know what I mean?
Who was the other guy they had?
They had an African or they've had a couple of African American quarterbacks.
The last guy cried.
You know what I mean?
So they're like,
all right.
You know what?
We'll just have a coach.
Coaches don't cry.
Players cry every once in a while.
You know they,
how was that guy's name?
I don't fucking know.
Anyway,
so I actually saw some cool when I was coming into decent time.
You fly into DC,
there's always some sort of presidential contact.
You know what I mean?
You feel like he's right around the corner.
You're going to see him.
All of a sudden they block off the streets.
You could stay here longer.
The motorcade goes by,
right.
And all the jaded people who fucking does this thing keep cutting out.
I hope it doesn't cut out.
No,
no.
Cause it's keep going.
It keeps going right.
This just fucking awful.
How do you guys learn about this shit?
You know what I mean?
They did.
Things just shows up and it doesn't fucking tell you anything.
And then what?
You got to go into those little chat rooms.
Okay?
Send a couple of emojis.
The the please help me.
I'm an old man fucking Emoji.
Is that what you're supposed to do?
Well,
that's a fumble,
right?
Nope.
Uh,
he dropped the pink football.
All right.
Anyways,
some I'm driving into DC.
I'm might actually riding in and um,
I see this fucking helicopter just fucking cruising.
Okay.
Look like it wasn't any more than 200 feet off the,
uh,
off the surface going right down the fucking Potomac.
You know,
I see how it's got the Alec and sees the Red Lights,
so I know it's going from right to left because the red is always on the left.
The green.
Your position.
Arie likes in aviation,
the green,
the green is always on the right.
And uh,
the other one's a that will whatever the fucking,
the left is always the red.
I actually took offense to a ground school.
It's like,
why are we read?
Why is this going back to the 18 hundreds when she wrote with the left hand you
with a devil,
you know this fire and health,
the devil's read,
right?
Is that what the fuck it is?
And if you're on the right,
you sat on the right hand of the father and it'll,
all your fucking options are open to you.
Is that,
what,
is it above anyway?
So the thing's fucking cruise around.
The dude driving me and said that they,
whenever they fly the president via helicopter,
that they always have three helicopters and he's only in one of them.
Right?
So if anybody's going to try to do anything crazy,
they got a one in three chance of fucking,
uh,
I dunno,
making it happen.
I have no fucking idea.
But speaking of that,
you know what,
I actually,
um,
I bought another one of these yachting magazines because I know it's just
fucking hilarious to me that the,
the,
this one's called showboats,
right?
And on the cover it says to boldly go where no man has gone before.
And then talking about the northwest passage from death trap to Trendy fucking
transit.
And the Bermuda Triangle to tales of the unexplained.
So that was actually interesting as as hell.
But then like peppered in between the stories is like,
like this,
like an advertisement full,
like a $250,000 fucking watch,
watch,
my voice should have cracked.
And so we just can walk around with the Ferrari and then they got this one page,
it says owner's club where readers of the magazine,
you become part of the owner's club and he sent in a picture of you and you
creepy fucking rich family,
you know,
so they got this old ass fucking guy,
right?
He looks like he's at least 70 his wife's in,
is it an,
it looks like to be in her fifties botox down and then they got three fucking
creepy kids that are like only in like their teens and twenties you know?
And they all looked a little fucked up,
you know what I mean?
Because rich people want to hold on to their money.
So they sit there and they,
they kind of fucking the same culdesac out there on the Hamptons.
And after a while they all start looking like each other.
You know what I mean?
Then they got these weird sort of ailments,
like pure bred dogs.
Like they can't go swimming because there is always fill up with water.
It can't come out and then they get like these fucking infections is something I
have no idea what.
Anyways,
these kinds won.
It starts sailing up the Amazon River.
Do you don't even realize there's no fucking way I'm going to be able to do the
advertising because I'm too afraid to leave.
I'm too afraid to leave this area.
Like it's going to have my phone,
like it's going to shut off so I'm just going to have going to have to go
straight through.
Okay.
Like I said,
dude,
if you guys are actually hearing this as an absolute miracle,
so anyways,
these kinds want to fucking,
you know,
sale their yachts up the Amazon River.
Why would you want to do that?
You know why?
Cause she's sick of going to these fucking eyes wide shut parties.
And no matter where you took your yacht,
there's some other contact going like,
oh yeah,
I'd taken my boat there and you want to have something new to talk about,
right?
You got a $250,000 watch,
he's got a $260,000 watch.
You feel bored.
You know what I mean?
How are you going to get some 50 year old botox woman to come over and jump on
your 80 year old Dick,
you know,
and fuck you on your Helo pad on your boat.
How the fuck are you gonna do,
do that?
You know,
you got to take your boat with no other people go.
So these costs are going to go up the Amazon River,
right?
And uh,
you know this pristine area,
you got people living up there where a,
you know how people used to live hundreds of thousands of fucking years ago or
whatever the fuck it is.
I don't know.
But you know,
what's cool is this pirates up and down that thing.
So at some 0.1 of these rich countries is going to get killed.
I guarantee it.
I can't,
I even give a fuck if they can't like board the boat.
At some point someone's going to be like,
well fuck it.
Then I'll just climb up a tree and I'll shoot one of these fucking darts at them
or whatever they do.
You know,
know after some cannibalistic fucking,
uh,
tribes out there,
how great would that be?
How great would the fucking meet be those rich people,
they must be like veal.
Yup.
After all these fucking years of fighting all the tribes,
you know,
these guys are fucking,
climbing trees and running through the forest to fucking athletes did,
did tough.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if take this NFL game here,
man,
if you were going to eat somebody who went to this NFL game,
right?
You wouldn't want to eat an NFL player.
I'm saying it's a plane crash.
He had a fucking dude,
you're on the team flight,
right?
You don't want to eat it and it fell flat.
I mean,
that guy's fucking shredded.
You know what I mean?
Maybe alignment.
Debbie.
I've eaten like a fucking rib eye,
you know.
Nice and marble.
Find a good cut of meat.
Fucking underbelly would be like that fucking the underbelly.
Like all the Japanese guys like that fucking a,
that Sushi.
Right?
That's fucking disgusting.
But I'm just saying,
so what is disgusting to us?
Because we have all these options.
You know,
first world problems is people like to say I love when people say,
oh first world prob,
well I live in a first world,
so everything I have is a first world problem.
I could be completely fucking dead ass bro.
A homeless guy in the United States has first world problems.
Okay.
Shitting on a subway grate,
you know what I mean?
Exposing himself so he can get a night in jail and maybe maybe get some fucking,
some porridge,
whatever the fuck they feed prisoners.
All right.
That's still a first world problem cause he's part of our economy.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You know it's funny is so many lives in a third world can't get it,
can't get a girlfriend.
Is that a third world problem?
It's still third real problem.
He's in third world and no one will his dick,
right.
I need some clarification on this.
Anyway,
so what the fuck was I talking about?
Okay,
so he got these fucking tribes or whatever.
These people that,
you know,
they got one pair of shorts that whole life,
you know what I mean?
The environmental footprint,
the carbon footprint is,
is,
is basically nothing,
you know,
and now here come these rich concept,
the river Ed,
I'm calling it right now.
Yeah.
For the first time in the history of the world,
a billionaire is going to get eaten.
I shrink down his fucking head.
You know,
I don't,
what the fuck's going to happen is watchful end up at the bottom of the fucking
Amazon.
Um,
it really is actually know something.
When I was,
there was,
there's a lot about,
um,
to be serious here for the first time at 21 fucking minutes.
There's a lot about,
okay.
Owning a boat and navigating it.
That overlaps with aviation as far as like campuses and,
uh,
okay.
You don't magnetic deviation and variation and uh,
dead reckoning.
And then also the sinking fucking feeling that you just
killed yourself with something out of the ordinary happens when a light comes on
or something like that.
I,
there's no way,
unless you fly or you,
you own a boat and you leave where you can't see land,
there's no way to describe that fucking nauseated feeling of,
Oh fuck am I that guy?
Um,
what's your course is totally balanced out by the unbelievable thrill of it.
I remember I took a long time ago,
well,
not long time ago,
I was like three years ago,
but it seems like a long time ago I was,
um,
I was in Boston,
I was staying in the North End.
It was fucking great.
And when I was doing that movie,
the heat and um,
my wife came to town and so I wanted to take her out and they had these,
these water taxis.
So I was like,
oh,
I had a little romance to this thing.
Well,
jump on the water taxi and we'll go over to this different part of the city.
We'll go get something to eat or whatever.
I came up with the fuck are you doing?
And I got to tell you something,
man.
The second I got out there on that boat,
all right.
And we were going by,
and it was this guy knew all the shit and he goes over that giant boat.
You see a giant bolt right there that bolts on by the,
uh,
the fucking,
owner of the red sox was this giant fucking yet,
right?
And I'm terrified of the ocean and that type of shit.
You know what I mean?
And,
but I got to met the second I got out there on that boat immediately.
The temptation to do something fucking illegal was,
was what was off the charts.
I,
there's no way I could own a boat.
Well,
I would do it.
The fear of fucking going to jail and getting fucking butt raped and always
keeps you in line,
doesn't it?
But still,
you know what I mean?
You just thinking like,
dude,
nobody's gonna stop.
What are the,
what is going to stop me if I took a key low from this city to another city,
you know,
then you got to interact with them,
right?
Who the fuck she going to give you a Keela what the flux sec I got to do.
All of a sudden he fucking,
he comes on the boat with you and next thing you know he'd peek.
Yeah,
he does a Kleinfeld right?
One of my favorite fucking characters of all time.
They ever tell you guys how much I love that movie that I can't remember the
name of,
but I know,
remember Sean Penn's characters name Carlito's way
lawyer.
You ate a lawyer.
Client sells you a gangster.
Um,
Hey,
I'm not getting mad at Ya.
That guy when he's got the fucking the cough.
There's a lot of great character actors in that movie.
But anyways,
um,
I ain't with that.
Fuck.
I'm talking about fan duel.
Can I make fun of Fan Duel?
They've never fucking advertise in this podcast.
Do you realize how fucking,
how fucking reprehensible it is that,
that all of these,
these sports leagues are getting in bed with the sports book after all these
years of them fucking sitting there talking about how,
you know,
the gambling ruins their sport and a day,
as long as it doesn't ruin their sport,
they don't give a fuck what happens to your life.
You know what I mean?
And if you've noticed in the,
you know what,
I don't give a fuck if they never come back.
I can't,
I can't.
I got to say something here.
I just have to,
it's,
it's just,
it's low hanging fruit,
dude.
You notice in those commercials all they show is like three or four fucking
winters.
That's it.
Okay.
The rest of them fucking lose.
I gotta tell you sent demand,
like that fucking gambling thing is a god damn fucking disease that you do not
want to get involved in.
I'm telling you right now.
Okay.
You know,
it's funny as I'm going to shit on it and I also have a great idea for it.
All right.
I think it's,
it's,
it's an,
it's actually not even reprehensible that baseball after what they've done with
Pete rose and that type of stuff has gotten bed with these fucking guys.
I will say this.
Um,
it's just,
it's almost,
it's more,
it's kind of just honest,
like,
yeah,
all we give a fuck about is making money.
Like we don't give a shit.
I mean,
what are they going to do next?
You know what I mean?
What the fuck are they?
Do you know what they're going to do is they're going to legalize weed.
Weed's going to be legal and then they're going to have commercials on TV and
they'll get in bed with those fucking guys and they'll sell it.
Players that they can't fucking use it as,
he can't,
can't smoke weed.
You can't gamble,
but our fans can do whatever they want and then you just start,
you know,
just start selling cocaine.
Just have them advertise,
fucking blow,
you know,
those,
those movable fucking,
uh,
billboards behind the home plate or whatever.
Um,
now having said all that fan duel and draft kings,
I have a great idea for you guys if you want to land a well,
all right.
Cause probably what you're thinking right now is all right,
well we're getting all these bottom feeders.
You know,
cause you know like basically you pick your team and then you have a salary cap
and you know that the salary cap basically represents those,
you know,
the green zero in the green double zero on a,
in the roulette wheel,
which I'm,
you know,
I'm certainly not a mathematician,
but from what I've overheard in conversations in bars is that unbelievably tips
it in the casinos favor to the point they can't fucking lose.
Right.
Which is the whole point of open and a fucking casino.
I mean you don't want to fucking lose.
So you know,
the salary cap represents the green zero in the green,
double zero on the fucking a roulette wheel.
So I have an eye itself,
maybe,
I don't know if you want to attract a bigger spending clientele is you let you
let the,
the,
the super rich.
All right.
What they have to do is they have,
you have a luxury tax you,
you,
so you basically make it like a soft cap like they do in baseball,
right?
Where basically everybody has to adhere to this salary cap unless she got money
like the red sox and the Yankees,
at which point you can go beyond it,
but then you have a luxury tax except the luxury tax doesn't go to the poor
bastards who fucking lost their shirt.
Like basically the bottom feeder gamblers who are like the Kansas cities and
those teams who Kansas City's back now,
no disrespect them in San Diego or whatever.
These teams that can't afford to spend money like the Yankees and red sox
basically.
Right.
Instead of the money going to them,
it goes to you guys at Fan Duel and draft kings,
right?
And then all you do is have your nerdy mathematician.
Some comes from MIT.
Figure out a way that with the luxury tax it looks like,
you know,
they can feel the better team and it looks like the odds are increasingly in
their favor,
but they have to gamble a certain amount of money.
You got to put a certain amount of money down and then you do a little fuck you
fuck with the numbers with the nerdy little MIT mathematician.
And next thing you know you've got some way along the hook and now he's chasing
it,
right?
He's still in the luxury tax thing,
one of those fucking Wall Street cons,
you know,
so they go,
so I Shit on you and also give you a decent idea to just have one of your nerds
work it out.
All right,
there you go.
MMM.
I'm walking around for some dumb reason.
Uh Huh.
We're at 29 minutes.
I got another 50 seconds to eat up here and then I'm going to watch this fucking
game and I'm going to order room service and I'm not going to drink and I'm not
going to smoke a cigar.
Even though last night I smoked two cigars back to back and I had a couple of
drinks.
I'm trying to everybody,
you know what I mean?
I got my fucking vices.
Um,
I had a good idea for cigars too.
I can't remember what the fuck that is.
I literally feel a cold coming on.
This is how old I am.
I fucking stayed in a hotel for fucking 30 minutes doing this God damn shit with
the air conditioner on and I feel like I'm having a cold,
having a cold,
catching a cold.
All right.
Anyways,
the reason why I'm all over the place as I'm so fucking anxious that I'm not
going to be able to figure out how to fucking upload this thing onto Dropbox.
Why do you keep fucking closing on me?
I got to put the password in.
Um,
all right,
whatever.
That's 30 minutes now.
You know what?
Now I got to fucking,
uh,
well let's see if I can do this.
Let's see if I can close this.
Oh,
it is still recording.
It's still recording.
Would you look at that?
All right,
so I can do my advertising.
I'm looking at this and I don't have to fucking copy and paste some shit
together.
All right,
here we go.
Oh my God.
There's a ton of them.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody stopped shaving with an a you fucking motherfucker.
You stop.
Stuff keeps popping up on the screen.
Okay,
let's try this again.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
I'm on my best behavior this week.
Stopped shaving with an old razor.
It's gross.
Why are you torturing yourself with the gross old blade week after week?
Probably because you don't want to shell out 20 bucks for a pack of new ones.
Dollar Shave Club has revolutionized the way men shape.
With Dollar Shave Club,
you could shave with a fresh blade as often as you want because they deliver a
whole sleeve of amazing raises for just a few bucks a month.
The razors are so good.
Millions of guys have joined.
Even the billion dollar razor corporations are freaking out.
I love this,
this paragraph,
but instead of lowering their bloated prices that trying to fool you into
milking the same blade for an entire month and that's gross.
Uh,
they've price gouged for low us for long enough through,
this is like the Napster of a a blade.
This is totally going to bring down those,
the blade industry.
I'm calling it right now.
Would you pay more?
I'm never go back to squeezing weeks and weeks and shaves out of the disgusting
Rusty Blade.
Joined Dollar Shave club and use a fresh blade whenever you want.
It feels amazing and it's just a third of the price.
It's a no brainer.
Join the millions of others who figured,
figured out the smart way to shave.
Joined Dollar Shave club now by going to dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar hey dollar shave club.com/barb.
All right,
club Dubby Club Derby,
uh,
9,000 years.
That's how long humans had been making wine.
That's also how long they'd been confused about which wine to drink.
Some people get a headache after they drink wine.
I do.
Red Wine crushes me,
but for many of us it's the shopping part that causes the real headaches.
So I thought you had to come up with a wine that doesn't give me a headache.
It's actually the next day.
Anyway,
so many choices,
so much to learn and so expensive with no guarantee.
You'll leave in like what you by picking out a good wine can be difficult.
Beer nerds go on and on about hops,
it micro brews,
but at the same time it's frowned upon to care about good wine.
Research has shown most people buy based on the label.
Those are terrible odds to play your own personal experience learning about wine
or why you haven't to learn about wine if you haven't bothered to learn about
wine.
Oh,
was I supposed to do some,
you know,
I should really read.
Oh,
I should put my own personal experience yet.
The way I read out loud,
people know I don't know shit about wine,
although I do love a Barolo.
All right,
and I don't let the acidity one.
I like the fruity or one.
Was that nice?
Did that work?
I just signed up for club w no,
I didn't.
Okay.
Yeah.
My wines are on the way.
No,
I didn't.
I know I have some wine on the way.
I'm going to try it first and then I'll do it.
All right.
Look if you rent a wine,
okay.
Okay.
This is actually a great idea.
Did the fucking copies horrific?
Um,
but it's,
it's a great idea because there are,
there's a zillion of them.
You know what I love too is like directors make wine.
You can get like a fucking Sean Penn and red.
It's like,
you know,
I like his movies but I mean,
does he have time to know about this shift?
Hey,
why did you get some Tom Hanks head cheese?
I,
it's easy.
You just go to club Dubby Club W.
Dot Com and answer six simple questions.
Their algorithm creates a palate profile just for you.
Then they just send the wine directly to your door,
perfectly customized to your match and taste.
This is insane,
dude.
You not anything enough to think in the future?
Um,
club w is the leading.
Okay.
Is leading the grape to glass wine revolution.
They work directly with vineyards to cut out the middle man,
which saves you money.
So with club w you get premium wine,
customize your tastes at a third of what you pay at the store.
They even have a no risk,
a hundred percent guarantee that you'll love,
uh,
that you'll love what they send you a call to action offer.
And Right now club w w is offering my listeners 50% off your first order when
you go to club w.
Dot com slash bar this is great.
The holidays are coming up,
right?
So stop wasting time and money messing around at retail stores and start
drinking wine.
You know,
you're going to love.
Just go to club w.
Dot com slash bird to get 50% off your first order.
That's club w.com/burr.
Sorry guys,
I've got to plow through these men.
Uh,
and then we'll then we'll do a little throwback half hour from yesteryear.
Um,
legal zone.
You shouldn't have to choose a random lawyer who charges expensive hourly rates
when you need legal help.
But the legal system is so complicated.
What other choice do you have when you need help with your business or want to
protect your family?
Start with legal zone.
They make it easy for more than a decade.
They provided a way for regular people like you and me to confidently navigate
the legal system.
No.
Yeah.
Legal system,
legal zooms not a lot from,
and that's how they provide such great value.
They don't rely on charging you by the hour.
Instead,
you'll get transparent pricing and customer reviews so you know exactly what
you're getting up front if you need help within corporations,
LLCs,
trademarks,
last wills,
living trusts,
and more legal sumps the smart choice.
They've got the right people on hand to answer your questions and if you need
legal advice,
their network of independent attorneys can provide the straight forward guidance
you need.
And most states don't let legal hurdles become an excuse.
Go to legalzoom.com today to start building your own future,
the right way to save even more and to burn in the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com promo code burr to more everybody.
Zip Recruiter.
As a business owner,
your company is only as good as the people you hire.
Posting jobs in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
Touchdown Ravens.
Uh,
short staffing leaves little time to post to dozens of job sites.
Position Ziprecruiter's as the solution.
What does that mean position Zip recruiters as the solution?
Well,
it shouldn't.
You do that with the copy.
Look,
you can post.
All right?
You want me to do it then?
If that's what these capital letters mean,
I'll do it.
Look,
you need to hire somebody,
right?
If you just post the one place,
you use a finite amount of people you can get to.
If you go to Ziprecruiter,
you,
you're going to be used by over 400,000 different businesses.
Okay?
You can post to 100 plus job sites with just one single click.
Be instantly matched to candidates from over 6 million resumes plus watch brand
new candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface within 24 hours.
This is great for people looking for a job.
It's great for people trying to hire.
All right,
um,
call to action.
Okay.
Today you can try ZipRecruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash per one
more time,
ziprecruiter.com uh,
slash burn the last one,
Uber.
Oh,
I thought these guys dropping.
Hey,
you like making great money,
Huh?
Here's a really cool opportunity I had to share with you.
I had to share it with you.
Driving with Uber.
Uber is that popular smartphone APP that connects writers with drivers.
Uh,
you can take Uber a bunch,
you'll love him by the way.
And in chatting with the drivers,
some of them have really interesting stories as to why they drive Uber.
Uh,
they love being their own boss there.
They liked her.
Erin,
uh,
extra money or just great money in general.
It's easy to start.
You just need a car and a license.
Driving with Uber is great for anyone who needs flexibility.
Parents,
this is a really easy way to work around your family schedule or avoid a
loveless marriage.
Students,
you can make some extra money in between classes and not have to work at a titty
bar or maybe start Sharona,
you know?
Yeah.
Illegal drug thing.
I Dunno.
Now's the prime time to cash and driving with Uber.
You'll thank me for telling you how to get paid every week.
You know what?
There's a chance I could be getting into your car when you drive Uber.
It,
I can tell you right now,
I won't be sober.
Uh,
just drop me off anywhere near where I say call to action.
You got a car,
you gotta license.
Pulled them both to work.
If you start earning serious money,
life changing money today,
sign up to drive with Uber.
Visit drive with uber.com that's drive with Uber.
Calm U,
B,
e,
r.
And that is it.
All right,
and that's the,
the end of this podcast.
And I hope you get to listen to this cause that means I did it right.
Okay.
God bless you.
I have a great weekend.
You constant.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
Never seen things done in a negative one.
New York.
Dagos Gagliano because the top of the Rock,
Flagstaff and a man,
New York,
God goes,
goggle and on top of the rock.
Can I digress for half a second?
Do you know it's the 20th anniversary far Nirvana's nevermind.
And I bought spin magazine.
They had this giant article and everybody was talking about it and uh,
and for the majority of people were just like,
dude,
when that album came out,
man,
I was just like,
fuck hair metal.
This is something different and it's fucking over.
Was I the only guy who heard that Alma was just kind of like,
hey,
you know,
I kinda still like Whitesnake.
I did.
I was too far down the hair metal trail.
I didn't realize how good nirvana was and I hated Pearl Jam.
Fucking hated them.
I hated Eddie Vedder's stupid.
I'm in a trance on purpose face who he ran hello when he sit there and he'd be
fucking have his arms up and his wrists were all fucking limp and he was making
those faces on fucking purpose.
He looked like he should have been a wrestling or something.
He's crazy.
Eddie Vedder.
Um,
I hated that fucking,
I still hate that fucking album.
Okay.
We even flow.
Hate it.
I liked their other stuff.
Vitality.
I like what he stopped making the faces.
You know what he was like,
he was like Mel Gibson in the first lethal weapon when he was fucking acting
like he was suicidal and it was so awful.
They had to make him stop.
That's what Eddie Vedder was like,
d in the first Pearl Jam.
And then,
and then they'd go to fucking interview.
Do you ever see that interview?
Kurt Loder did.
If somebody can find this fucking video,
they interview Eddie vetter and he's like literally in like the fetal position
making this face.
Like he doesn't want to be interviewed.
It's like Eddie,
you don't have to do the interview.
You could just say,
I'm suffering from exhaustion and everyone will think you have a coke problem,
but who gives a fuck?
Right.
So I wasn't in any of that shit.
I didn't get into,
uh,
Nirvana until probably 1993.
Okay.
And by then I noticed everybody was wearing flannel shirts and a smashing
pumpkins and all my bands were gone.
Banished,
never to be returned until that,
that metal show came back triumphantly to bring back my music.
But uh,
yeah,
I was late.
I was definitely late,
so I was,
I guess,
I mean,
I guess the article would suck.
I'm such a moron.
I was upset that no one said that.
Basically in the article,
like why would they say that bill?
They're trying to commemorate a fucking masterpiece of an album.
Why would they have a bunch of people going?
You know,
I thought I didn't think anything about it at that Pearl jam sucked,
but I really,
I was still listened to
no,
the fuck I was listening to
the fuck was I listening to when the early nineties I actually tried to get into
jazz.
I was flailing and just completely not progressing in my drumming at all.
So I thought,
have I listened to jazz?
I would get better.
And I liked big band swing and then,
you know,
I,
I saw all the great drummers.
They used to go to the regatta Blah in Boston.
I saw Tony Williams,
I saw Tony Williams in a fucking bar that held like a hundred people.
Louie Bellson.
I went up and shook his hand.
I'm standing behind his drum kit.
It was fucking ridiculous.
Roy Haynes,
I saw Max Roach,
I saw all these guys didn't improve my drumming at all.
That's what the fuck I was doing.
And I was hanging out with my drum teacher who is like 70 years old.
Uh,
I dunno if I need to add this at this point,
but yes,
there was no pussy in my life at that point.
So anyways,
yeah,
I kind of missed the beginning of the grunge thing.
I'm not a Gen X.
I think I'm old enough to be gen x,
but I'm not.
I am a hair metal fucking eighties kid.
That's who I am.
I watched family ties,
a full metal jacket,
the lost boys.
That was my shit.
That was when I came up.
I can't help it.
That,
that's what the Muse,
I thought Cinderella was a good band.
Okay.
What did I know?
Just a fucking redhead kid in the middle of nowhere.
Um,
yeah,
so they would just,
everybody was just going,
I just heard it and I stopped in my tracks and I was like,
what the fuck is this?
It's like,
how did,
how did everybody know that?
Okay.
You know,
I've ever being annoyed by the,
uh,
that their first video when Kirk goes to take the fucking solo and he pretends
like he's tapped like doing the tap on Solo,
like basically making fun of all the bands that I was listening to and I was
kind of like,
who is this Douche?
You know,
you call that a fucking Solo,
just basically playing the goddamn melody of the song through a fucking
distortion pedal.
I'm not saying any of these thoughts were right.
I think the guy's a fucking genius and the album's fucking unbelievable,
but that's where my head was at.
That is honestly where my head was at.
Like I went,
got when Axel rose had his running backstage with them at whatever award show
that was when the,
uh,
the bass player and now senator threw it up in the air and it fucking crashed
out on his forehead.
And I believe Dana Carvey was hosting going.
Did you see what that fucking guy just did?
I was rooting for axl rose.
Okay.
I think the only thing that I did respectively respectively as far as my music
listening between 1988 in 1992 was I never bought guns and roses.
Use your illusion.
One or two.
I hated the fucking band by that point when they had dizzy and Lizzie and all
these other fucking guys,
and they had Matt Sorum and the whole fucking band was gone and then he was
running around and God damn biker shorts and he had that stupid white fucking
wind screen.
Then I'll hold it just,
yeah,
I was unfucking believable.
It just went right down the shitter.
Okay,
so that's where I was at.
I was sitting there going,
I can't believe they kicked Steven Adler route,
but guys are phenomenal fucking drummer.
Okay.
Change the whole sound of the Goddamn band.
Now as he left,
that's what I was thinking of.
I wasn't
okay.
My Libido love us Keto.
Look in the windshield.
Is that a mosquito?
I wasn't listening to any of that.
Yay.
No,
I didn't listen to any of it and then that fucking dude came on.
That's when I started feeling old.
I think when that,
when that album came out and then smashing pumpkins came out
and whatever the fuck he was singing about cats,
Siamese twins,
that,
how was that song?
I don't know.
This pat all my wage,
all that shit.
I was trying,
I was trying so hard,
but by then I was like 25 years old and I got to tell you,
it's fucking over.
Silver music is for young people.
Um,
all right.
There you go.
If you wanted to relive the early nineties through my fucking eyeballs there it
was Jesus Christ.
Was that long enough for you
gum,
the negative one.
All right,
question a question number two.
Hey Bill,
a regular listener and first time writer,
I need your advice on something.
26 years old and I was together with a lady for close to a year and a half bef
for dating her.
I was pretty much a dog.
Uh,
you know your typical man whore type.
No,
I know nothing about that.
Um,
I basically bang anything with a skirt on it.
Well,
don't ever go to Scotland.
Thank you.
Oh,
be heroes.
Uh,
but this thing,
but this girl was different.
I knew,
I knew her for a while before we started dating and we were amazing friends
anyways.
I won't Blab on too much.
Uh,
but dating her was great relationship with their dad was good.
So,
you know,
she didn't have any issues and shit,
but like in the middle of the relationship,
I noticed her coworker would be extra flirty with her and stuff.
Oh,
Gj age.
Ugh.
If this was a TV show,
they would introduce that and then they would go to commercial and you'd be like
up a die.
But I want to see what's going to happen.
Well,
here we go.
We're back from commercial.
I always told her how it made me uncomfortable and that and shit that the dude
always tried to get with her and stuff.
Wait,
I thought this was a woman.
Oh,
I immediately assumed it was a woman.
I wanted this to be,
uh,
oh,
this is a guy.
Oh,
that's extra.
Jesus.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
These God damn fucking women.
What did she do to you?
Serve.
Do I really got to read this?
Do I,
do I even need to read this?
Okay.
You totally loving her,
your complete fucking friends with there.
And then she's flirting with disguise,
flirting with the too much,
and all of a sudden now you're not going out with her.
Ah,
God,
this God Damn God damn motherfuckers.
All right,
let's,
let's plow ahead.
I just needed to regroup.
Um,
so anyways,
I told her how it made me uncomfortable and shit,
that the dude was always trying to get with her and stuff,
but she always assured me that she didn't like the dude and she doesn't respect
guys like that who hit on girls even though they are taken.
Okay.
Bull is she,
is she telling the guy to leave her alone?
Okay.
Jesus Christ,
a couple of months passed and then an incident happened.
She was at an office party and according to her,
the dude got super drunk and kissed her.
Anyways,
this happened on a weekend and came clean about it the next day.
Her excuse was that he got drunk and kissed her so it wasn't her fault and that
she didn't kiss him back.
So it,
nene means there's nothing there.
Of course,
I didn't listen to that bullshit and I dumped it within 10 minutes to be told at
that time out a second.
I'm going to give you some applause.
There you go.
Exactly.
I don't bind to that crap that she didn't kiss him back cause in my head it's
like she's saying,
oh,
he had his dick in me,
but I didn't fuck them back.
So it's okay.
Thank you sir.
I don't even need to answer this.
You got your heads right where you need to be.
What does a guy ever said?
Oh honey,
don't worry.
I didn't kiss her back and gotten away.
Scott free.
If a guy said that he would have got the shit kicked out of,
uh,
out of him by his girl.
I remember the old uninformed episode where you and Joe were talking about
Michael Richard to some PR guy.
And Joe said the problem with the whole situations that Michael Richards
squirmed when he was apologizing and didn't just own up to,
to his fault,
that's why he wasn't forgiven.
And that's the logic I use here,
that if she just owned up to it,
that the dude kissed her.
Um,
I could deal with it better than her saying she didn't kiss him back because
back.
So I should be okay with it.
Okay.
And he goes,
Oh my God,
I'm basing my relationship decision on what Joe de Rosa says.
I think I've hit a new low anyway,
not to make these email too long,
but three months since we broke up and I'm not really sure if it was the right
decision.
My Gut said I did the right thing,
but I'm questioning it dude.
You're questioning it cause you,
cause you love this girl on some level and because you're lonely and you're
going through this shit.
But Dude,
fuck that.
All right.
No offense.
But that Bitch was disrespecting you from day one when that bull shit was
happening,
this guy's drunk.
How did your lips do?
What he's,
what did he fucking run across the room?
Like a superman punch,
but with his lips sticking out and she was talking to somebody else and came
over and he was drunk.
What do what?
What led up to the kiss?
What the fuck were they talking about?
They were talking about shit that leads up to a kiss and you're fucking goddamn
whore of an ex girlfriend sat there in that fucking moment,
letting your pussy get a little bit wet but not really fucking doing it.
Fuck her,
Dude.
I'm telling you right now.
That was the tip of the goddamn iceberg.
That's the lock the door test to the 10th fucking power.
If you ever saw a Bronx tale,
that's it right there.
You 100% made the right fucking decision.
You're still a young guy.
There's a better one coming your way.
Who won't be fucking flirting with some Dick at work and accidentally getting
kissed and you think that that's the only thing that happened,
that he accidentally just kissed her and that's where the fuck it's stopped.
He didn't accidentally brush against one of her titties.
Fuck that dude.
You did the right thing.
Football season's coming.
All that money you would've spent on her.
Go get yourself a dish and get the fucking NFL package.
You deserve it.
All right,
go on youtube.
Learn how to cook a perfect steak on a Hibachi and enjoy your fucking team for
16 games.
I'm telling you,
let her fade the fuck away and get yourself a decent woman.
Good for you,
sir.
I applaud you.
I applaud you for the fucking decision you just made there.
That did.
That was like,
it was like an in gymnastics.
When you just stick the fucking landing 10.0 it's over.
Give them the gold medal.
You did the right thing.
Fuck her.
All right.
That's just the loneliness.
Okay?
You'll find another gore.
Good ones are hard to find.
So it's gonna take longer than three months,
but okay.
But the last thing you want to do,
it's over.
The trust is gone.
It's fucking over.
All right?
If you ever think of going back to our relisten to this part of the fucking
podcast,
it ends at four 49 minutes.
53 seconds.
So fast forward to that.
Rewind to whatever fucking two minutes.
Ah,
Jesus Christ didn't kiss him peck.
Yeah,
he didn't kick him in the balls either.
A yell rape.
How the fuck did he kiss you?
That's fucking great.
You've done good.
I hope she learns a lesson.
I got
good at a moon moon.
You stuck,
crafted and the number comes we've smoothed out already.
Like just
sake of the women who have influenced female style and the last fucking 25
years.
I'm really going to sound like an old guy,
but I just think that they dress like absolute trash it fucking trash the car
dash Egan's that's your pinnacle of fashion sense.
Huh?
Those squirrel died horse.
Stay looked like to me like if I ever wanted to fuck a Gofer,
if I was ever turned on by a,
uh,
by a rodent
and who came before them?
Who was before them?
Paris Hilton,
Paris.
Fucking Hilton.
Just,
just fucking head to toe.
Just dot.
By the time she was fucking 19,
she was just used up.
Now how do you think she got that way?
Everybody thinks because of what?
Because what?
She was some uh,
some rich guys.
Fucking kid.
That's how she ended up that way.
No.
Who was before her?
Madonna lay it on this stage.
Fucking spreading a God damn legs.
Just trash.
She's trash.
It's all,
it's bread spent fucking trash for 30 fucking years
and you go back,
you watch,
you watch all those old movies,
this fucking women that beautiful,
but they got,
they got class and you know what?
They would probably suck in as much dick is the girls do today,
but they didn't wear it on this sleeve.
Okay?
Fucking tattooed God damn horse.
They would just fucking bring their asses down just a little bit more.
You know,
Scott's a little bit longer.
Leave something.
The imagination.
You don't think so.
All you guys are,
I wish Jay walked around naked.
You never had that moment in a titty bar when you walk in,
you just said at some point it's just not even exciting anymore.
You're actually talking to a completely naked woman asking her where the
bathroom is.
You know?
There's no excitement anymore.
You're talking,
you're used to it.
You fucking used to it.
Speaking of which,
speaking of which,
what's the deal?
They had a protest here in New York City.
It was evidently a,
yesterday was go topless day.
It said protesters went over the top for the right to bare breasts.
Almost three dozen activists strutted through Columbus Circle Circle yesterday
on national go topless day.
Similar demonstrations were held across the country demanding that lawmakers
trash codes against female toplessness.
Um,
I don't know why they want to fucking do that,
but you know,
more power to them.
I guess the good looking ones.
That's how I was,
I would ease into that law.
You got to demonstrate that your titties should be shown the same way when you
see a guy walking around with man tits and you like put a shirt on.
Right?
Okay.
I think that,
I think you should earn being topless.
How about that?
Okay.
You know,
I sound like a dictator,
but if I was one,
that's how I would run my country.
You got to earn it all right?
If you're a guy,
you gotta be jacked.
And if you're a woman,
you're your tits have to still be excited about life.
They can't be those beaten down tip staring at your toes.
You know?
You know what's interesting is in a lot of third world countries,
women walking around with their titties,
hanging out is a,
is,
is no big deal.
It's not a a,
they don't give a shit.
So I was just wondering,
are as men here in the states and uh,
are we turned on by titties?
Just because we've,
um,
I think that's what it is.
You know what?
That's exactly what the fuck it is.
Because those old school chicks,
the Mary Tyler Moore's with that goddamn skirts below the knee,
do you know if every girl was walking around with skirts below their knee,
your whole fucking life?
And then one day some girl comes walking by energy your in are just,
her skirt is above her knee.
I swear to God,
you're going to get a semi.
You're like,
Holy Shit,
I can see your knees.
You know,
women don't,
don't do that with Teddy's,
you know,
can we still be excited to see a fucking titties?
Isn't it enough?
Don't you get enough in this country?
You know,
you get to run your fucking yaps all God damn day long be as rude and
inconsiderate as humanly fucking possible and it and no one slap you in the
face.
We can't do it anymore.
You know say Ya Yap,
Yap,
Yap.
Right?
You get divorced,
you get to take a guy for all these fucking worth and they'd be out just to
girl,
I can't work work for me.
I'm used to a certain lifestyle.
Isn't that enough now?
Now you're going to re,
you know you've joined all our fucking men's clubs.
We can't even get away from you.
And one of the few pleasures we have left in life is the excitement of seeing a
pair of tits,
talking our way and to see at a pair of fucking tits,
right?
Couple of blue moons in a,
you know,
a Belvedere or some shit.
You get her to do it and now you're going to take that away by just walking
around with your God damn titties hanging out.
What would Audrey,
Audrey Hepburn say,
hi.
What?
What the fuck would she say?
Is that the right one that,
that breakfast at Tiffany's chick.
I use that fucking express that,
that,
that reference that.
I've never seen that movie.
I've just seen pictures of it.
And I think that that girl is,
she's a class act,
unlike all you filthy whores nowadays with your hoary little car Dashi and shoes
with the fucking Paris Hilton Jizzum on my face straps and the Madonna hoary
fishnets you know,
I know a lot of you guys because Madonna's like 63 at this point,
has been living in England for 20 years.
You actually think that she some high falutin she's the daughter of a trucker
from Michigan.
Don't ever forget that.
All right.
And she's not full of me with a goddamn accent.
Uh,
Jesus.
Why am I trashing the Donna so far?
My feet waiting in the winter wireless.
Matthew.